[music playing]
A young girl who might be
interested in pursuing magic
just might not even think
of it as a possibility
because the magician she sees
on television are all men.
[music playing]
I first got started in
magic when I was 10 years old.
I joined the society
of young magicians.
And I was the only girl who
was a part of the group.
Magic has a woman problem.
The tradition of magic
that is practiced now
evolved from the late 18th
and early 19th century,
when there were women,
but they were assistants.
But they were actually very,
very skilled magicians.
And it's built into the
art, the way the magician
and the assistant interact.
The powerlessness of the
assistant-- which is actually
just a ruse to make you
think she's powerless
and strengthen the trick.
We enter into the mystery,
and we are transformed.
If you look at the women
of the vaudeville era,
they were doing magic.
They were plucking
coins out of the air
and manipulating
cards and reading
minds, all on their own.
Adelaide Hermann was the first
successful female magician.
And in 1899, Adelaide,
at the age of 46,
debuted her solo magic
act in vaudeville
as the queen of magic.
Audiences just loved
seeing a woman doing magic.
She immediately was
booked at the Winter
Garden theater in Berlin,
in London, and in Paris.
She was a headliner.
She was a particular
favorite of ladies,
as much for what she would
wear as for her magic.
She was often written
up in the fashion pages.
She was a huge hit.
People loved her.
I think the time for women and
magic is finally happening.
This whole creaky
gender bias machine
is just breaking at the seams.
Jen Kramer is one of those
new up and coming magicians
who amazingly, at a very young
age, has her own Las Vegas
show.
She's very much like
Adelaide in that
she's heading her own company
out there in the world.
And she also, like Adelaide,
reaches out to her audience.
[music playing]
If a young girl sees my
show and feels inspired,
that would really
mean a lot to me.
Because magic is incredible,
meaningful part of my life.
I'd love it if more young
girls are able to have
that experience, as well.
Magic is an art that
continues to evolve.
The techniques change,
the props change,
but the personality
of the magician
is what shines through.
You see that spark of charisma,
that spark of talent that
gets people excited,
and they want to watch,
and they want to know.
And most of all, they
want to be reminded
that anything is possible.
March On.
Celebrating women who
changed the world.